[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
so
[Laughter]
too
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
so
hey you guys here we are yeah i was
sitting here [ __ ] making eyes with
pookie what you doing
hey what's up we were just we were just
talking about her little
baby days talking about when i first
time i saw a damn video of her
and it was she was in a bird cage in
somebody's garage and
smacking a damn ball or something on the
end of a string or some kind of hamster
wheel or something
i was like yeah okay we'll take it yeah
we'll take her it was like it was a
friend she was like
that big yeah she was little yeah
there's a friend of his mom's like found
her in the backyard and we've been
talking about getting a kitten anyway
and she's like yeah
sends us like a [ __ ] mom send me the
video of it and i'm like yeah okay
i mean like i said you can't send me
pictures or videos of the kitten
that'd be like hey you want this kit and
i'm like yeah [ __ ] yeah i want that kid
brought the cat home
first day and she's like i'm not
standing in the garage and said no put
her in the bed with us we were getting
ready to go to sleep and the [ __ ] cat
went
looked at both of us and we looked at
each other and just everybody's just
looking at each other
yeah turn the light off and went to
sleep woke up and she was still there
sleeping in between us
yeah yeah she didn't like hide or
nothing for the first she was a little
wigged out at first because beijing came
over and she was like oh no a baby
like that she was like yeah and then
like the second day they're making bread
on making bread on on jenny doing this
yeah she still does that every now and
then yeah she loves this
she loves right here like where my neck
meets my shoulder
yeah i have to sleep with a blanket
piled right there because otherwise
she'll just claw right into it
all right enough of kitty madness let's
get let's get to uh
kitty madness listen let's let's uh
let's talk about the movie that we saw
yeah okay so we're doing a matinee today
uh this is
actually this just dropped on shutter
yesterday i think
now it's weird because it said 2020
on shutter however when i kind of looked
into the past of the movie
it actually premiered at a horror
festival no poke no
oh in late 2018 no
and went to streaming i think in like uh
on sale like with dvd and blu-ray and
[ __ ] like that in
march of 2019. so this isn't actually
like a brand new brand new movie
but we only just saw it because like i
said they just put it on shutter and
it's only like a year or two old so
it still counts this is actually called
30 miles from nowhere
now interestingly the poster of it
kind of looks like a generic slasher
movie
cabin in the woods kind of movie it's
really not like that though
and i feel like um but if you look it up
like on imdb it's not actually listed
so much as a horror movie it's more as
like a comedy thriller or like a horror
comedy
so it definitely does i think lean more
toward
the comedy end than the horror end that
said
i liked it a lot now i can see how some
people might not
um depending on what your sense of humor
is but
one thing that i kind of like this i saw
one reviewer call it the big chill meets
friday the 13th
which i thought was kind of accurate
that's kind of accurate it's a bunch of
people like in their 30s and 40s
it's like a slasher but instead of
teenagers they're in their 30s and 40s
and they're all trying to [ __ ] each
other too and they're all about we have
drunks yeah and that's about what
happens
based on our experience those
[ __ ] are always trying to [ __ ]
us
[Laughter]
i'd be sitting there [ __ ] hurt never
mind no
no no we'll be outside the damn club
when there's [ __ ] these couples man
[ __ ]
jenny be standing right next to me and
some girl come up and just start rubbing
on my titties and [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] you doing and her husband
is [ __ ] chatting her up and [ __ ]
the more and we know him and that's what
happens when you get [ __ ] too many
goddamn old people together
they all start trying to [ __ ] each other
especially when they're drinking
which is that which is what i liked
about this movie now this that's there
that they show
that yeah and it's like and i'm not
going to say like a lot of the
characters because like you said like
probably about 10 or 20 most of the
characters are not like they're
unlikable but i think they're kind of
supposed to be
like they're kind of supposed to be
[ __ ] typical [ __ ]
new england [ __ ] not well uh
northern yankee [ __ ] yuppies
that's kind of middle-aged middle-aged
kind they're kind of like
you know probably middle class upper
middle class but they didn't like
do as much as they thought they probably
should have and so they're kind of like
at the mid
midlife crisis point yeah and totally
[ __ ] corporate and mainstream and
[ __ ]
yeah so like i said i don't think
they're necessarily supposed to be
likeable
no i don't think they are they're
they're supposed to be mundane because
it's supposed to be funny
yeah and uh one thing i will say like i
really like um
it was directed by caitlyn caller and it
was actually written by
shauna ko foid i guess is how you
pronounce your last name who is actually
also in
the movie as elaine who was probably my
favorite character she was like the
drunk lesbian
but she had my favorite there's a lot of
great lines in this movie like the
the script of it it's almost altman-like
uh in the way that like a lot of the um
conversations are kind of like over each
other so it's like realistic
but um they're all very sarcastic and
mean and backbiting
yeah and it's like they're all trying to
like get one over on each other and
everything's they're
all they're all very venal kind of
characters yeah about whose degrees
better know what their jobs and just
[ __ ] like that it's just like i said
they're real mundane [ __ ] yuppie [ __ ]
which that's the way they are that's
what i mean that's what i thought
and i also liked i said it's kind of
refreshing to see
i mean i wouldn't i don't know if i
would call this a slasher maybe it does
have some tropes of slasher
but it doesn't necessarily go in that
direction like it is i'm not going to
spoil it but
it doesn't end up in that kind of place
but it does kind of have that sort of
structure to it
but it's nice to see like a slasher
adjacent type of movie
that's all like cranky grouchy drunken
middle-aged people rather than a bunch
of college kids exactly
but my interpretation of it my
interpretation of it is that it's for
the generations that grew up with the
[ __ ] early friday the 13th and all
the slashers
like we did yeah so i think it's aimed
at our age group
mostly oh the young young kids would
like it maybe i don't know
but i think it was i think it's for
[ __ ] xgen
x generation mostly it may be because
like i said we know people like yes
it's it's it's a it's a throwback
slasher movie for ex-generation
yeah with a bunch of cranky middle-aged
people which are ex-gen yep and it's
just very very funny
it's like like i said so the so the
woman that wrote it that plays elaine
she actually gets my favorite line in
the movie which is like
you know she's kind of like they're all
kind of drunks but she's kind of like
the worst drunk
and she's complaining because somebody
finished off the wine and then one of
the other friends is like
you have a drinking problem she goes no
[ __ ] duh yeah
i wish i thought i'm like yeah that's
exactly what she would answer
but yeah so basically what happens what
the setup of the movie is
so you have like these uh five or six
[ __ ]
and uh they yeah like i said they are
kind of they are kind of [ __ ] but
they're funny [ __ ]
like i said they're very sarcastic and
they're always like talking [ __ ] about
one another and
you know doing [ __ ] behind other
people's backs and you know it's
[ __ ] like that so uh they're like
frenemies i guess
so uh they're apparently they're they're
uh
originally i guess they're all from
wisconsin i'm assuming this was shot in
wisconsin
um but they've all subsequently moved
away except for one of them whose name
is sylvia
and her husband max who was uh you know
they were all like one big friend group
has ostensibly uh shot himself
and so all of these other friends are
coming back
for his funeral and uh so there's a lot
of
tension between like all the friends
because
i feel because they haven't like they've
kind of drifted apart and then they say
they're like best friends and blah blah
blah but it's like they don't
they're not real supportive of one
another it's like you know you didn't
even come to any of my kids baby shower
you didn't come to this event so they're
always like complaining and bitching at
one another and moaning
so they end up at this uh at sylvia's
place
in wisconsin and they're staying in her
guest house um
you know prior to going to max's funeral
and uh [ __ ] starts getting weird uh
particularly sylvia
who is you know the widow and she's
acting a little bit sketchy
um you know which they kind of point out
but it's kind of like everyone's like
yeah whatever [ __ ] it we're just here
for the funeral and
they don't really seem all that sad or
anything they just come with booze
and it's like they're just hanging out
and they're all drinking and throwing up
and
trying to [ __ ] one another's girlfriends
and all this other kind of [ __ ] when you
get to a certain age the hormones are
not the same it's not like
it's not like teenagers teenagers will
[ __ ] fight each other over some [ __ ]
like that
they're easily [ __ ] offended you get
to a certain age and they're like yeah
well you know
well once you get to a certain way
you know they're just trying to [ __ ]
you're not taking this seriously which
sounds nice
i mean you do still i mean you know i do
still give a [ __ ] about things
yeah it's just but it's like it's not
the same there's some [ __ ] that you
don't
you can't really get all that you can
get worked up about yeah it ends up
being just be
it's just funny they don't mean any
insult by it and it's you know and it's
more
and it and it's actually kind of
liberating like you're not really giving
a crap about a lot of stuff
that's just what happens when you get
old but like i said so
um so this movie basically like i said i
don't
know it has some horror elements but i
don't
i wouldn't call it a straight horror
movie or even a slasher movie even
though it kind of is
set up like that um it's more of like a
mystery thriller but i think
comedy is the most um is kind of the
most prevalent thing
because pretty much for most of the run
time it's just these characters um
bitching and fighting with each other
like over what they're gonna do
about all this like escalating weirdness
that's going on
at this wisconsin [ __ ] you know house
you know what i mean they're kind of out
in the middle of nowhere 30 miles from
nowhere as they say so they can't
there's no cell reception there's like a
storm coming uh according to sylvia the
road's been washed out so they can't
leave
it's like you know they can't get food
delivered they can't get this done the
other the you know the power goes out
and then like you know there's it's just
like little things happen there's like a
roach infestation there's all this other
kind of [ __ ] going on
so as all that's going on everyone's
like getting tempers are afraid and they
all just start like
you know pissing and moaning at each
other and like trying to figure out
what's gonna happen
and like i said there's a twist to it
and like you do find out what's going on
but this is definitely a movie that i
think
um you would probably need to watch
twice
because i mean i think i got the gist of
what was going on it kind of lost me a
couple times
but yeah it's one of those ones where if
you're not really paying attention to
the end you're gonna be like wait what
so you really have to i mean the more i
thought about it i was like oh okay yeah
i get it and then there's like another
like you know kind of twist at the end
where you're just like oh [ __ ] you know
what i mean
yeah but it's definitely one where if
you weren't paying attention the first
time you'll probably have to watch it
again i like the movie
it's on shutter so you don't have to pay
for it if you guys shatter
all right it's uh production
value is good the quality is pretty good
uh the acting's good
shot real well it had a good tone to it
um i would say there's only one thing
wrong with the movie what's that it
didn't have a very exciting score or
soundtrack actually it needed a little
bit you know what i'm talking about i
didn't notice
actually it needed a little this the
score actually
it wasn't bad it needed a soundtrack
yeah with some with some you know you
know i mean with some songs in it or
something at certain times during the
i remember on the outro i remember
liking the opening song but i don't
remember any of the other
yeah it was like that's what i'm saying
it had a serviceable score
it wasn't didn't really stand out yeah
but uh
that's the only thing i can i can really
criticize now and i'm going to say it's
not
super gory no it's not it's not um
you know fourth road round says it
sounds like the big chill but with
murders it definitely is like it has a
very big chill
type of you know all these middle-aged
people that you know used to be friends
but they're all kind of like really
jealous of each other and
they're always they you know they they
haven't really been that great of
friends to each other so they're always
like fighting
nothing was that there was there was no
nudity in this
there wasn't it's weird because it was
one shot because one of the friends
uh i think his character's name is jack
yeah and he
is uh he arrives late and he comes there
with his 23 year old
girlfriend so there is like one younger
person yeah so there's like conflict
there as well and then lesbians trying
to like make a move on her because she's
pretty
yeah um and she's kind of a party girl
um
i think she does flash her tits for a
second but i don't think you see it i
think you only see it from the back
for what they were trying to do with a
slasher and trying to appeal to x
generation
it it should have had a lot more nudity
in it probably they kind of missed the
boat because that's what
that's what the genre was yeah and
that's what the dialogue was demanding
yeah they were talking yeah they were
talking sporty to one of them
i thought some lesbian action was going
to break out at any minute they started
talking about teddies and [ __ ] in new
york
your titties are like oh yeah let's see
them pull them out
you know i mean there's all kinds of
[ __ ] that should have happened then
there's some some like
interracial [ __ ] almost happened between
a white dude an asian girl and then the
asian girl and a black dude
and it looked like all this [ __ ] was
gonna happen they're like well why
didn't it happen
i talked about it if you mention the
[ __ ] in a movie like this
you gotta show it it's like if you're
not gonna show it and shut the [ __ ] up
it's like chekhov's gun
but it's like check off sex talk yeah
yeah if you say it you have to that's
another
that's another criticism i can give the
movie but over oh but all in all it was
it's it it's satisfying watch you know
yeah
like i said just don't go into it
expecting it to be like a slasher movie
because it actually is more of a comedy
than anything else
but it has like a lot of slasher or
mystery thriller elements yeah
it's kind of hard to explain that's why
i liked that that reviewer said that
you know um said uh friday the 13th
meets the big chill because it was kind
of like that
except not as gory like you know what i
mean are not liz overtly slasher
um because it's not really a slasher
it's like some
other weirder [ __ ] that's going on you
know what i mean that you kind of find
out
um but yeah i liked it i like because i
it kind of kept me
invested in like what the mystery was
what the [ __ ] was going on why was
sylvia acting so weird
um you know they they find like some
weird [ __ ] like in the basement and
stuff that's kind of like oh that's
unpleasant
and [ __ ] like that so you know it had a
good uh
time saying old people like nudity too
well here's another thing
you don't even actually have to show the
nudity
you just you just have to let people the
audience know that the nudity happened
like remember remember in that damn
movie about the porn stars what was the
name of that movie
no i had to [ __ ] had bart reynolds in
it oh and oh the old one
boogie nights boogie nights yeah burt
reynolds
you know he meets dirk diggler you know
what i mean
and [ __ ] he goes i've heard that
you're very talented and all this kind
of [ __ ] and he's like yeah i'm very town
he goes
let me see it and [ __ ] dirt [ __ ]
pulls it out on him now from the angle
you can't see it yeah but
you know [ __ ] bart reynolds could see
it they showed at the end though
yeah i guess they did didn't they but
yeah burt reynolds scene
he just like he's and he's hit like like
he's star struck
you know what i mean remember i love
that and he just goes into this
he goes and he loves this meat gazing
spell
and then he shakes it off he goes thank
you dirk thank you
thank you that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
over the [ __ ] moon that [ __ ] was over
the [ __ ] time
that was the [ __ ] one of the greatest
scenes of all [ __ ] times
just his facial just his facial
expression and then his
thank you like he had witnessed the
[ __ ] modern
like like a miracle of nature or some
[ __ ] yeah
and you see it yeah if you're gonna if
you're gonna talk about it at least
do something like that you know what i
mean to [ __ ]
pull the audience in you know because
that was the equivalent of like in
in pulp fiction when [ __ ] what's his
name opens the damn briefcase and all
the [ __ ] golden light comes out
you never see what it is yeah yeah yeah
i don't think they ever decided it was
it's like i i feel like
sometimes filmmakers put [ __ ] like that
in their movies just to make people talk
about them yeah after i don't think they
have it couldn't have been gold that
much gold would have [ __ ] been so
heavy they wouldn't be able to carry it
was heavier than lead
i think jesus was i guess it was just
supposed to be heroin or something you
know but it was like
light gold
enough to [ __ ] you know retire for
five lifetimes
street value you know it'd have been
really funny if like
if he made a sequel and they found out
what was really in there and it was just
like one of these lights like we have
it's like just glowing yellow
i'm going to tell you all a story tell
your story about a secret
about a secret pass a secret package
i read a biography of of howard hughes
and part of the biography was written
by stories or the source was
how one of howard hughes right hands man
who was actually just a boxer hired off
the street and [ __ ] hughes
had him trained and put him in charge of
the entire the managing the [ __ ]
hughes empire because he didn't trust
lawyers or anything else so he made his
own basically manager
okay yeah hughes disappears for like two
years
they don't know where the [ __ ] he is
this is when he was going into his
[ __ ] real crazy period after all
those heads throwing his fingernails and
pooping in bottles and stuff yeah
so uh out of nowhere this [ __ ]
manager who was
you know who used to be a boxer i forgot
what his name is gets a [ __ ] phone
call and he goes
i need you to come get me because boss
is that you and he goes yes i need you
to come get me
and he gives him [ __ ] he gets it
gives him
where you know tells him where he's at
he's at some place that hughes
owned where they both knew some business
and when he shows up he's got this old
[ __ ] jalopy
all right and he opens up the back and
then he goes he
brings he brings his guy into the
[ __ ] office and he goes in the back
in the back of that car there's a truck
i want you to take the trunk i want you
to [ __ ] wrap the truck and [ __ ]
number three butcher paper i want you to
[ __ ] wrap the outside of it with
twine
that you know that and he gave him the
the [ __ ] diameter the twine you know
what gage twine it was
how to wrap it what kind of knots to use
and this shit's going on for a long time
tell them how to wrap this [ __ ] trunk
that's in the [ __ ] truck of the car
all right and he goes then i want you to
fill i want you to build an airstrip
and this shows him where he wants to
build a [ __ ] private airport
he says i want you to [ __ ] connect a
road from the airport to this road here
and i want you to put a guard booth here
and then the guard booth next to the
airport i want you to put this [ __ ]
uh uh he has it like a little building
built not very big like one room
tells him he wanted a window united air
conditioner he had to [ __ ] get the
electricity out to it and he just tells
him to build an airport a guard booth
a road out to it okay and this
building that's air conditioned a little
building with a window in the unit he
goes and then i want you to take that
trunk i want you to put that in there
and i want you to lock it
and then if i can lock the outside of
that door and i want it i want a
telephone
going to the guard tower and i want a
guard on it i think he wanted two guards
or one guard or two
on it 24 hours a day he tells him what
[ __ ] company because they own he
owned
security companies too how many ships
and all these [ __ ] details
about guarding this [ __ ] trunk and he
had been gone for like a couple years
because he just used to disappear
so a guy his manager's like man that
must be some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in that town
so that they do it they have it all
built because he had construction
companies hughes basically owned all the
united states at that period of time or
at least
the fbi wasn't sure how much of the
united states he owned but he could
probably
single-handedly collapse a stock market
if he did something crazy so they had
him under
observation all the time so they get all
that [ __ ] built
like pretty quick in a matter of a few
weeks
with a little air strip to get to it and
everything
and he has that he has that [ __ ]
trunk put in there
and forgets all about it like six seven
years later he gets a [ __ ] phone call
and it came from that facility and the
guard there said
uh some water built up in that air
conditioner it dripped out through the
front and got on top of that down box
and it's
it's soaked in through the paper because
they they were told to check it every
few months
yeah and he had forgotten all about that
[ __ ] box
you know that trunk and he goes i gotta
go to see what this is you know what i
mean he
took some dudes with him too and they
were gonna re-wrap it with paper just
like they did before so boss wouldn't
find out
and as they were re-wrapping it they
said let's open it
it's like i'm dying let's open this [ __ ]
and they were really thinking the worst
all right they opened didn't know it was
in there wasn't it
they were re uh roy roger or red writer
comic books something
red writer comic books and a bunch of
douche douche bags
and douches with dates on them nice
that's a howard hughes story he's like i
need to keep this stuff this stuff
is very he built a [ __ ] airport and a
guard booth and [ __ ] a whole building
to [ __ ] guard
some douche bags some douches and comic
books
so that's that's where they don't really
think they even sell douches anymore do
they
oh just like two bags they're they were
all dated
they were all dated who's were they they
don't know
they never they never asked him they
never asked boss they just put it back
it's like yeah
that's the craziest [ __ ] ever the one's
asking where they used they said
evidently they were used they were
all rounds they were they were coiled up
and then taped nicely
that he had done it and then they had
little tags on them with dates
that's just so weird yeah with a bunch
of comic books that weren't worth
anything back in those days you know
they were worthless comic books yeah
it's like they were around right
nowadays they would probably be worth
something
maybe but not then it's just funny
because
i'll although i don't know if i had all
the money like on earth
i might do something like that just to
[ __ ] with people just like
the most random [ __ ] in there and just
like make that now you can never ever
open this and i'm gonna put it in a
[ __ ] vault and i'm going to put like
alls and i'm going to put a dragon
outside and do this that and the other
and everybody's like curios would be
like freaking out and they open it and
they're just like just yeah
there's like a stale hostess cupcake in
there yeah hughes was like that but he
wasn't pulling a joke
he really was yeah he had real bad ocd
and multiple head injuries
and um he would start glitching out and
uh
doing weird [ __ ] with and then he would
go hide for several years
and try to regain sanity and fight his
way out of it and uh you know
that was one of the little things he did
do a show about howard hughes oh yeah
i'm surprised that we haven't done one
up to now howard was [ __ ] cool i
liked howard
um it wasn't his fault that he went that
way
well it's a mental illness it's like he
didn't really have any choice in the
matter did he
well the ace the ocd didn't develop
until after multiple [ __ ] repeated
head injuries
yeah from crashing airplanes and cars
and that's where it came from
and we're talking about like four very
serious traumatic head injuries within a
short period of time and that's kind of
where all that
all that came from and he owned a
[ __ ] huge empire
yeah and they stole his money basically
well that's what happened if you
yeah he had a [ __ ] he had a private
investigation
security company that worked directly
for him
that was um made up of guys from the
church of latter-day saints which is the
mormons
he liked them because they didn't drink
and they were honest
and they didn't give him any kind of
problem about having multiple
girlfriends
because you know this is a long time ago
yeah
and they were the most high-tech
best-trained
intelligence unit in the united states
in fact the cia or excuse me the fbi
modeled themselves after hughes's
network yeah
um but anyway uh over time when
hughes started to weaken they siphoned
this his security agency
siphoned most of his money off of him
and into the
to the church and with it they built
salt lake city yeah and and their church
that's like so honest after all well no
they knew he was dying
yeah they were they were doing that and
they knew he was out of his [ __ ] mind
and he was dying
so that's and he didn't care i don't
think
he just wasn't just like he didn't care
he didn't really care about money
towards the end yeah i guess not he was
running for money
okay let's end the show yeah you did
oh yeah i want to say um yeah zach said
uh he wanted he'd kill to see a show on
howard hughes okay
you know what i will put that on because
you guys if you are one of our patrons
which i know most of the people here are
um i'm gonna start doing those polls
you're gonna be able to pick
what the topic for the following show is
gonna be
and what the movie retrospective for the
following week is going to be
and i'm going to start putting those
polls up this
friday so it's not be so when you choose
a
when you choose a um a topic for the
show
that it won't be like for the next day
it'll be like for the following
week you know what i'm saying because i
still need like a week to do the
research and [ __ ] like that
but if you're uh if you're one of our
patrons even at like you know
you know the first tier or whatever go
over there on friday i think i have
about
10 a.m uh eastern standard time and vote
on
there's five choices for each thing so
you can vote on uh what thing you want
exactly is it hold on zack's saying he
thinks hughes was a an
ass had asperger's no he didn't he
didn't he was a regular
he was actually a genius he was a
broadband genius
and he didn't go to school he just hired
tutors to come and teach him
like top and he said he knew aviation
technology and all kinds of stuff
he was extremely intelligent well a lot
of well asperger's is too yeah but
there's a big difference he was also
[ __ ] it's very socially
outgoing and [ __ ] was
thank you mango was part thank you very
much megan for the show on saturday
and i'm not i'm so scared to watch it
now
he bought him he bought rko bought he
formed and bought
he formed rko pitchers so he could date
uh
movie starlets he was socially extremely
functional
so now he didn't have asperger's yeah um
his problems developed after he crashed
the first one happened when he crashed
an airplane and hit his head on the
front it was like a world war one style
biplane
and then he started [ __ ] wrecking
cars and airplanes he
refused to go to the hospital or get any
treatment when he was obviously
one of the time i think he was in a coma
for a few hours i think
he'd get out of the damn hospital head
injuries head injuries
multiple head injuries that [ __ ] you up
and then with that he
he got ocd from that well even one head
injury will [ __ ] you up i mean how many
multiple head injuries how many [ __ ]
serial killers have we talked about that
like got a head injury when they were a
kid and then they turned it became
serious yeah
i'm not saying that was the only you
know he had repeated ones and probably
worse than what a damn american football
player would have had
and uh good thing he didn't he didn't
really drink so i think that
that helped out if he'd been into drugs
and alcohol it would have been even
worse
well yeah and he was under a lot of
stress and somehow this caused the
formation of
obsessive compulsive disorder and
insanity you know repeated thoughts over
and over and over your head which is
yeah head injury stuff
yeah and that's that's ocd i mean yeah
compulsive because that's like a thought
you can't like you can't get rid of it
glowing turtle said i picked up lone
wolf and cub criterion collection on
your recommendation
good stuff thanks it's so i mean
aside from the movies being awesome that
[ __ ] collection is so so beautiful
yeah that was the original mandalorian
yeah that one and somebody else we i
found a video that mentioned that
yeah which is weird i totally didn't see
that beforehand i was just thinking that
cause i'm like oh it's like a tough dude
and a baby and they just go from like
place to place
it's like the lone wolf yeah a lot of
star wars was was borrowed from samurai
movies
yeah definitely yeah definitely all
right let's go ahead and let it go
yeah so uh like i said if you like
horror comedy uh you know kind of
the snarky variety then you will
probably dig this it's on shutter called
30 miles from nowhere came out in 2018
but [ __ ] it we're
reviewing it now but yeah so uh check it
out and we will talk to you guys again
tomorrow bye